this video was made possible by tab for
cause raise money for charity just by
opening up new tabs which you were going
to do anyway link in the description
several states have enacted major
anti-abortion laws of the hope of
overturning Roe vs. Wade which gives
women a constitutional right to an
abortion what are all of these laws
about what does Roe actually say about
the right to an abortion and the right
to privacy and where does Planned
Parenthood vs. Casey fit into this
picture in this real Law Review I'm
going to try to bring some clarity to
this charged and fluid situation to get
there I'm going to talk about the
history of women's rights in America
discuss what has happened recently in
Georgia Alabama and Missouri and the
laws that they passed and explain what
could be ahead for the Supreme Court
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer look I know that this is a
hot-button issue I have very strong
personal beliefs about this and I'm sure
you do too I'm going to try to do my
best to separate out my personal
opinions because the law whether you
accept the outcome or not is fairly cut
and dry as always Stella appreciates and
encourages a robust discussion but
Stella will bring down the ban gavel on
anyone that is rude or disrespectful in
the comments all right but let's get
straight to it what is up with all of
these new abortion laws that are
cropping up mainly in the American South
well right now abortion is legal in all
50 states but legislators in Missouri
Mississippi Ohio Georgia Alabama
Louisiana and others are now racing to
see who can pass the most draconian
anti-abortion laws in America but there
is method to this madness Georgia
Mississippi Ohio and Alabama have
enacted laws making it illegal to
terminate a pregnancy once electrical
activity in the fetal heart is detected
these are the so called fetal heartbeat
bills now I recognize that this is a
charged term but it seems to be
popularly adopted so I'm going to use it
in this particular video doctors say
that this electrical activity can happen
as early as six weeks after
fertilization missouri passed a law
criminalizing abortions starting at
around 8 weeks under this law doctors
will get a prison sentence of three to
five years but women will not be
prosecuted Georgia's law which goes into
effect January 1st bans abortion once a
heartbeat is detected it allows for
exceptions in the case of rape or incest
but only if the woman files a police
report
Alabama's law contains no exception for
pregnancies that were the result of rape
or incest doctors performing abortions
under this law face ninety nine years in
prison pundits on both sides have
recognized likely unintended
consequences and nightmare scenarios you
can imagine the sad case of a teenage
girl who becomes pregnant after she is
raped by a father or uncle in Georgia
that teen would need to figure out a way
to report her father's crying to the
police in order to have an abortion if
she had an abortion anyway she could
face life in prison in Alabama the
doctor would also get life in jail the
new anti-abortion laws are intended
to have a chilling effect on the rights
of women physicians and others as what
tends to happen with the threat of
criminal prosecution undoubtedly some
women will be prevented from terminating
their pregnancy as we'll see the timing
of the bills and the burden placed on
women is of great constitutional
importance the lawmakers who drafted
these laws acknowledge that the laws
violate current Supreme Court precedent
but they decided to enact them
specifically to test current Supreme
Court precedent if this law goes into
effect in Alabama and it says abortion
is a crime that is in conflict with
Roe's interpretation and application of
the US Constitution so the law is
unconstitutional
once it is passed before it can go into
effect a lawsuit is expected to be filed
you're expecting to be sued of course he
passes a bill that he knows and they
have intentionally designed to be
unconstitutional right and the Planned
Parenthood's and the ACL u--'s of the
world they have to respond this of
course begs the very important question
how did we get here well let's start
with the very beginning of this country
after America gained its independence
the law largely remained silent about
contraception and abortion abortion was
legal from about 1776 until 1860 of
course things started to change after
the Civil War this was the beginning of
the Victorian era where preachers and
politicians started arguing that sexual
mores needed to become more restrictive
birth control and abortion were both two
of their targets along with anything
that implied sex might be a fun activity
to engage in anti sex Crusaders really
got going in the 1870s when the u.s.
Postmaster General Anthony Comstock used
the power of his office to enact laws
that targeted anything considered
obscene Comstock thought the government
had the power and a duty to restrict
what you could send through the mail or
say or read especially when it came to
sex and procreation during Comstock's 42
years at the US postal service
he successfully advocated for laws that
banned everything from masturbation to
contraception these Comstock laws as
they came to be known were passed in the
federal government and about half the
states in America
Comstock laws made it a crime to give
away sell or loan out any item
considered quote obscene or anything
that could be used for contraception or
abortion Comstock laws made it illegal
to use quote any drug medicinal article
or instrument for the purpose of
preventing conception violators could be
quote fined not less than $50 or
imprisoned not less than 60 days nor
more than one year or both fined and in
prison under Comstock laws physicians
were banned from even printing a
pamphlet discussing family planning as
part of this anti family planning regime
abortion became illegal in most states
by the early 1920s and of course that
didn't mean that there were no abortions
performed what they were often performed
in secret with wide disparities between
those who could find a doctor to perform
the procedure in secret and those who
were left to try to perform the
procedure themselves without any access
to medical treatment in 1930 alone is
reported that 2,700 women died in the
United States from abortion related
procedures while rarely enforced to the
full extent possible Comstock laws were
still on the books until 1965 when the
Supreme Court decided the landmark case
of Griswold versus Connecticut in 1961
Estelle Griswold was convicted for
violating the Connecticut Comstock laws
that prohibited anyone from providing
contraception or information about
contraception Griswold used her medical
clinic to provide birth control to her
patients William Buxton a Yale Medical
School professor was also convicted for
providing advice to married couples
about how to avoid pregnancy their
convictions were upheld on appeal and
they took their case to the US Supreme
Court now some of you may be wondering
how the government could interfere with
a couple's private decision about
contraceptives to begin with well the
Constitution enumerates individual
rights through the Bill of Rights the
Bill of Rights protects things like
freedom of speech the right to due
process under the law and the right to
be free of unreasonable searches and
seizures the word privacy is not
mentioned in the Bill of Rights or
anywhere else in the Constitution so in
the mid twentieth century there had not
been any significant case law allowing
people personal freedom over their
sexual lines however the Constitution
does not define every free
that it grants to the individual it has
been argued that privacy is implied in
many of the other rights the
Constitution does guarantee the Fourth
Amendment for instance gives you a right
to be free from unreasonable searches
and seizures that right is rooted in
your right to privacy in your own home
and body in the 1920s the Supreme Court
interpreted the Constitution to expand
individual rights for example in a case
involving whether a teacher could teach
children in the German language the
court ruled that the Due Process Clause
protects a person's right to marry have
children and to make decisions about
that child's upbringing using these
ideas Griswold and Buxton framed their
challenge to the Connecticut law as a
broad question about privacy itself the
Supreme Court agreed and the court found
that the state law which banned
distribution of contraceptives to be
unconstitutional because it infringed on
the general right of marital privacy
that was implied in the Constitution all
the Court recognized that the right to
privacy is not mentioned explicitly in
the constitution of the Bill of Rights
the Supreme Court said that you could
infer it from the quote pronoun as and
emanations of the Constitution in other
words the shadows and intentions of the
rights that are expressly laid out in
the Bill of Rights Justice William
Douglas held that the privacy right
emanated from the Bill of Rights he
cited the german-language case as an
example of how the First Amendment
prevents the government from limiting
the spectrum of available knowledge and
that same right also meant that Griswold
and Buxton were able to share their
contraceptive information with their
patients in addition the third
Amendment's prohibition of forced
quartering of troops the Fourth
Amendment's freedom from unreasonable
searches and seizures and the Fifth
Amendment right to avoid
self-incrimination all describe
different facets or quote zones of
privacy Justice Goldberg's concurring
opinion in Griswold also found a general
right to privacy in the text of a ninth
amendment which states quote the
enumeration in the constitution of
certain rights shall not be construed to
deny or disparage others retained by the
people many framers of the Constitution
though not all believed it was
impractical to list every freedom that
should be protected by the Constitution
itself
James Madison drafted the ninth
amendment to create a safety net for
liberties that are not enumerated in the
Constitution expressly and justice
Goldberg wrote that
the quote framers of the Constitution
believed that there are additional
fundamental rights protected from
governmental infringement which exist
alongside those fundamental rights
specifically mentioned in the first
eight constitutional amendments on that
basis Goldberg concluded that the right
to privacy is therefore one of the
fundamental rights guaranteed though not
expressly mentioned in the ninth
amendment so at base the court's
decision in Griswold gave married
couples the right to stop governmental
intrusion into their most intimate areas
of their life their sexual and
procreative life in 1972 in Eisenstadt
versus baird the court applied the
Griswold case to unmarried couples as
well former medical student William
Baird was arrested for handheld
contraceptives two unmarried persons in
violation of the Massachusetts state law
after Baird was convicted he appealed
his case to the Supreme Court which
struck down the law and overturned
Baird's conviction the court ruled that
the right to privacy they described in
Griswold wasn't just limited to married
people after all a married couple is
simply an association of two individuals
and quote if the right to privacy means
anything it is the right of the
individual married or single to be free
from unwanted governmental intrusion
into matters so fundamentally affecting
a person as a decision whether to bear
or beget a child the court also found
that denying unmarried people the right
to use contraception while allowing
married people to do so would violate
the Fourteenth Amendments Equal
Protection Clause it's important to note
that the Equal Protection Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment prevents the
government from arbitrarily treating
classes of people differently it was
argued that there was no legitimate
reason to treat married and unmarried
people differently for the purposes of
contraception law and in the context of
the current abortion debate many
attorneys believe that the Equal
Protection Clause is the strongest
argument for the right to abortion
because childbearing and laws that
especially concerned childbearing have a
dramatically different effect on women
compared to men one year later in 1973
the court decided the famous case of Roe
versus Wade which struck down a Texas
law to criminalized abortion in that
case Jane Roe which was a pseudonym was
an unmarried woman who was gang-raped in
Texas when she found out that she was
pregnant she trying to get an abort
but abortion was illegal in Texas except
to save the life of the mother she as
well as several other plaintiffs
including a physician challenged the
Texas law they alleged violated the zone
of personal privacy protected by the 1st
4th 5th 9th and 14th Amendment's
following in the steps of Griswold
versus Connecticut the Supreme Court in
a 7 to 2 majority vote held that the law
was in fact unconstitutional state laws
banning abortion except to save the
woman's life violated the Due Process
Clause of the Fourteenth Amendment which
protected the right to privacy the court
held that the right to privacy includes
a woman's qualified right to terminate
her pregnancy the court qualified his
holding by finding that although the
government cannot override the woman's
right to terminate a pregnancy it does
have legitimate interests in protecting
both pregnant woman's health and the
potentiality of human life to balance
the competing interests of the woman's
life and the potential for human life
the court said that the right of the
woman is the strongest during the first
trimester and diminishes as the
pregnancy continues through the second
and third trimesters Roe versus Wade
made three key rulings first it held
that a state could not outlaw abortion
during the first trimester at all second
it said that the state could regulate
abortion during the second trimester of
the pregnancy but only to protect a
woman's health and third it ruled that
the state could prohibit abortion during
the third trimester but not if the life
or health of the mother was at risk Roe
also set the standard for reviewing
future laws that implicated access to
abortion Roe's states that courts must
review such laws under quote strict
scrutiny which is the highest level of
judicial review to pass strict scrutiny
the legislature has to pass a law to
further a demonstrable quote compelling
governmental interest and it must have
narrowly tailored that law to achieve
that very compelling interest this is a
very very high burden in fact this is
the same standard that courts use when a
law restricts the freedom of speech this
is also a very important lesson in
constitutional law because sometimes the
most important decision in the Supreme
Court's opinion is the mundane
as to which standard to use it's going
to be much harder for laws to pass if
you use strict scrutiny which brings us
to the more recent case of Planned
Parenthood versus Casey while Roe versus
Wade gets most of the popular attention
is actually Casey that has been a
number-one target of anti-abortion
activists those who opposed abortion did
not go away after Roe vs. Wade
instead legislators use the state's
power which Roe explicitly approves of
to regulate abortion by creating laws
that made it harder for women to get
abortions so the case of Planned
Parenthood versus Casey dealt with the
state of Pennsylvania which passed the
abortion Control Act of 1982 which had
four regulations that restricted
abortion spousal notification parental
consent when the woman was a minor the
24-hour waiting period and a mandatory
disclosure of certain information in
1992 abortion advocates sued the state
alleging that these new regulations
violated roe versus wade now before we
talk about the outcome in Planned
Parenthood versus Casey first a note
about star a decisis story decisis is a
legal doctrine that theoretically
obligates courts to follow historical
decisions when ruling on a new case this
is also what's referred to as deferring
to precedent courts are generally
encouraged to follow their prior
decisions or similar decisions of other
courts in their geographical area since
the Supreme Court is the highest court
in America all lower courts are bound by
its decisions but all decisions of the
Supreme Court are co-equal to each other
so theoretically there's nothing that
stops the Supreme Court from changing
its mind year after year but the
doctrine of Starring decisis promotes
continuity over time it calls for
judicial restraint suggesting that
future Supreme Court's to carefully
craft ruling that respect precedent even
if they tweak the understanding of the
law so with the doctrine of stare
decisis in mind the court decided to
make Roe vs. Wade
more workable rather than just
overruling its central holding that
women had the right to terminate a
pregnancy so in the Casey decision the
Supreme Court actually upheld all of the
provisions in the Pennsylvania bill
except the one that forced a woman to
notify her spouse in order to obtain a
legal abortion at the same time the
five-to-four majority took this
opportunity to
reworked the trimester framework of RO
the opinion recognized that women do in
fact have the right to terminate the
pregnancy at certain times but also
overruled Roe's reliance on the
trimester framework instead the Court
emphasized that the key turning point in
a pregnancy was when the fetus was
viable meaning able to live outside of
the mother's womb medical advancements
had meant that fetuses could survive as
early as 24 weeks rather than at 28
weeks which had been the underpinning of
the Roe versus Wade decision as a result
the court drew a new line on a continuum
allowing for increased state interest
when a fetus reaches viability before
viability the state can have some
interest in fetal health as long as it
does not place an undue burden on the
woman's right to an abortion an undue
burden in this context is one that has
the quote purpose or effect of placing a
substantial obstacle in the path of a
woman seeking an abortion of a
non-viable fetus after viability the
state can regulate an even outlaw
abortion again however there is an
exception the States cannot outlaw
abortion if it is necessary for the
preservation of the life or health of
the mother the Supreme Court analyzed
the for Pennsylvania restrictions at
issue and found that only the one
requiring the woman to notify the father
was an undue burden if women could only
have an abortion after telling their
sexual partner it would give the man
substantial power over the woman's
decision which in some situations could
even lead to a spousal or child abuse at
the same time Casey held that states
could make an effort to convince women
not to have an abortion by doing
everything from making the woman having
ultrasounds who offering her mandatory
counseling but the state could not
prohibit women from terminating a
pregnancy so the essential holding of
Casey and the current law of the land is
that states cannot ban abortion before
24 weeks and laws restricting abortion
should be evaluated under the more
lenient undue burden standard rather
than a strict scrutiny analysis so now
what the new breed of anti-abortion laws
ignore the Casey framework about undue
burdens and instead the laws simply deny
the existence of a constitutional
privacy right that allows women to make
reproductive choices without
governmental interference the bill
passed by Alabama's law
for example contains language stating
that abortion isn't a medical procedure
it's a genocide on par with crimes
against humanity the state's new law
doesn't seek to throw women in jail but
instead it takes aim at the doctors
despite the protections of Roe and Casey
and the affirmation that there must be
an exception in cases where the woman's
life is in danger
Alabama carves out only a very narrow
exception for the life of the mother if
there is medical proof but the woman
faces quote a serious risk of
substantial physical impairment of a
major bodily function would any doctor
attempt to justify their medical
judgment that an abortion is necessary
when they could be convicted of a felony
and face up to 99 years in prison
meanwhile in Georgia lawmakers made a
different determination their law allows
women to be prosecuted for an abortion
whether it is performed by a doctor or
self induced women can get life
imprisonment or even the death penalty
Georgia's law stops doctors from
performing an abortion after they can
detect cardiac activity which happens
around six weeks however many women
aren't even aware that they are pregnant
after just six weeks which renders the
law pretty close to a total ban on
abortion which directly violates Roe and
Casey going even further Georgia's law
grants fetuses full personhood even
stating that they are to be included in
the state's census this legal personhood
status is the basis for one of Georgia's
most draconian regulations the limit on
a woman's right to leave the state to
have an abortion if a woman goes to a
state where abortion was fully legal the
woman could be prosecuted for conspiracy
to murder which carries a minimum
10-year sentence if someone drives the
woman out of state or otherwise helps
her they too could be charged with
conspiracy to commit murder
of course these new laws are in direct
conflict with constitutional precedent
because they make abortion during the
first twenty four weeks of pregnancy
completely illegal the laws ignore the
viability standard and instead pinpoint
the detection of a fetal heartbeat as
the time when the door to the abortion
clinic must be slam shut
they also ignore the Roe and Casey
Holdings estate they must make an
exception for when the life or health of
the mother is at stake instead these
laws come very close to outlawing
abortion oh my
what and no matter when so what is the
Supreme Court likely to do well in
recent years circuit courts have
carefully followed Casey and struck down
laws placing an undue burden on the
woman's reproductive choices for example
several years ago Idaho banned abortions
at 20 weeks after fertilization this
directly violated Casey's 24 week
viability rule Idaho regulations also
required all second trimester abortions
to happen in hospitals and place so many
safety regulations on clinics that have
made it nearly impossible for clinics to
stay open the legal regime made
obtaining legal abortion a minefield for
women like Jenny Lynn McCormick
McCormick was an Idaho resident who
wanted to terminate her pregnancy but
she could not afford to travel to the
closest abortion clinic in Salt Lake
City where she would have to pay $2,000
for the procedure
taking up McCormick's case the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals found that
Planned Parenthood versus Casey did not
allow the state to criminalize the act
of terminating a 20 week old pregnancy
the court also found that it was not
medically necessary for abortions to
take place at a hospital as for the
safety regulations Idaho's clinic
regulations included things like being
properly staffed or making satisfactory
arrangements with hospitals these terms
were so vague that they gave prosecutors
the ability to make up their own
definitions and then shut down the
clanks the Ninth Circuit followed in the
footsteps of Casey and demonstrates the
concept of starry decisis
however the justices on the current
Supreme Court have a very different view
of starry decisis Chief Justice Roberts
justices Thomas's Alito and Gorsuch have
been willing to overturn president when
they disagree with it and have a
majority even when they don't have a
majority these justices have often
written opinions advocating for
departure from long and standing legal
precedents the most recent significant
overruling of prior precedent came in
May of 2019 after justice cabin on
joined the court the conservative
justices overturned a precedent which
hadn't stood for 50 years the case
involved the jurisdiction of where
states could be sued just as Thomas
wrote that the court could ignore
principles of starry decisis when they
believe that the prior ruling is
erroneous in a dissent in that case
Justice Breyer who wrote the majority
opinion in Casey issued a warning about
the willingness of his conservative
colleagues to disregard
precedent stating it is far more
dangerous to overrule decision only
because five members of a later court
came to agree with earlier dissenters on
a difficult legal question the majority
has surrendered to the temptation to
overrule Hall even though it is a well
reasoned decision that has caused no
serious practical problems in the four
decades since we decided it
today's decision can only cause one to
wonder which cases the court will
overrule next
in other words Breyer is saying that
today's conservative justices will sweep
aside any rulings that they disagree
with on the other hand there is no
guarantee that the Supreme Court will
hear a case that presents the
opportunity to revisit Roe and Casey the
Supreme Court itself decides which cases
it's going to take up and here there is
no guarantee that any particular case
will ever be decided in the Supreme
Court these new anti-abortion laws will
definitely be struck down in lower
courts which must follow current Supreme
Court precedent but the Supreme Court
only hears the cases that it wants to
hear this is a process called Sur she or
I or cert for short
for example then Indiana Governor Mike
Pence signed the law making it illegal
for women to terminate pregnancy for
various reasons a federal appeals court
blocked the law and Indiana appealed the
Supreme Court has now reviewed the case
14 times without deciding whether it
would take it up or not that is without
granting cert to hear the case so
there's no question that the
anti-abortion laws that were passed in
2019 definitely do not pass
constitutional muster but that's only if
we are following Roe and Casey but the
Supreme Court has changed in recent
years and many legal scholars believe
that there could be enough votes on the
court to throw out both Casey and Roe
the fact that the court has yet to
decide whether to hear the Indiana case
also indicates that it may be debating
or revising its approach to abortion so
what will the justices decide when these
cases inevitably reach the Supreme Court
we have no idea
there's no witty remark or pithy segue
today when I cover stories like these it
just makes me want to do some good for
as many people as possible
if this video leaves you wanting to do
some good in this world
I'd recommend tab for a cause which lets
you raise money for charity just by
opening new tabs
the internet which you were probably
gonna do anyway tap for it cause it's a
Google Chrome extension that allows you
to pick the charity of your choice and
then every time you open up a new tab
instead of a blank page it displays a
beautiful new customizable tab with a
couple of tiny ads the money that you
generate is then donated to your charity
the gorgeous new tab is customizable
with widgets and my favorite it shows
you how much you are actually generating
tab for a cause users like you have
raised hundreds of thousands of dollars
over seven hundred thousand dollars at
the time of this video it is the easiest
possible way to donate to charity so
just click on the link in the
description and download the extension
and do some good by doing what you were
going to do anyway and open up a couple
of internet browser tabs so do you think
the current law is the way it should
stay or are you welcoming these new
developments in the American South leave
your objections in the comments below
and check out my other real law reviews
over here where you can learn about the
Moller report and all kinds of timely
legal issues just click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court